[Music]
the arrow versus crisis on Infinite
Earths is set to be one of the biggest
and best crossovers of all time it's
going to be bringing together one of the
most ambitious casts in comic book
history to provide a satisfying
conclusion to many DC movies and TV
shows welcome to that be spoilers show
everyone I am your host definition and
throughout this video I'm gonna be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the upcoming show this
video will cover the cast release date
as well as what the overall plotline of
the crossover could be about now there
may be some spoilers here so if you want
to go into the show with some surprises
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure that you subscribe to
the channel for daily breakdowns like
this and all of the updates on the
upcoming special without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of everything you need to
know about crisis on Infinite Earths ok
so the first thing that you need to know
about the special is that the entire
event will take place over roughly the
space of a month the first episode will
premiere at a p.m. on December the 8th
and run in a timeslot every day until
finalizing with the flash on December
10th we then take a big break until
January 14th which is when we get a two
hours special firstly starting with
arrow at 8:00 p.m. and then finishing up
with DC's legends of tomorrow at 9:00
p.m. this 5 hour crossover event is said
to be the biggest and most complicated
one that the CW have ever created and no
it's not out to LA apart of the air
there's already a ton of things that we
know this includes the show's massive
massive cast list firstly all of the big
players such as the arrow flash legends
of tomorrow and Supergirl will be making
an appearance as well as Black Lightning
and the newly introduced bat woman
Brandon Ralph though typically cast as
the atom will be appearing as the
Superman from 2006 in Superman Returns
in which he played the Man of Steel
which was connected to the Christopher
Reeve timeline on Friday the 27th of
November we got the first look at the
actor in his updated costume which bears
a striking resemblance to Alex Ross's
original design naturally the internet
exploded over the announcement and when
discussing the opportunity route said
the following playing Superman again is
an opportunity for me to kind
say hello and goodbye to the character
in a way that I didn't get to you the
first time being a young individual of
2425 I thought oh I'm going to be doing
this for years and make multiple movies
and that of course didn't happen I'm
just very honored to be able to do this
one less time this is of course great
news for fans who's similar to Roth
we'll be getting some form of closure on
what is probably the first depiction of
a superhero on screen that many fans
remember in addition to this the
Supergirl version of the Man of Steel
will be also appearing but these two
aren't the only versions of the
character appearing in the show Tom
Welling will once again be playing Clark
Kent from the Smallville Universe and he
will be joined by Erica Durance who will
be reprising her role as Lois Lane this
is some awesome casting news and feels
very much like the cherry on top that
cements this as one of the best
crossovers of all time this will carry
on their story as it was left off at the
end of Smallville and showcase how the
characters have grown since the
beginning unfortunately Michael
Rosenbaum declined to join the group for
the return and stated last week on
Twitter that he would not be appearing
in the show Kevin Conroy will be playing
a live-action version of Batman from the
Batman Beyond universe and personally
this is the announcement that I'm most
excited for Conroy in my opinion has
given the most iconic performance of the
Dark Knight ever since he first appeared
as an animated version of the character
and when this was first revealed I
absolutely hit the roof with just how
much fanservice it was providing Burt
Ward from the 1966 version of Batman
will to be popping up in Batwoman in a
minor cameo and this feels like a nice
little acknowledgement of the show that
started it all Tom Cavanaugh will be
playing multiple versions of Harrison
wells and also the pariah who appears in
the source material joining him will be
Lamonica Garrett who will once again be
playing the monitor and anti-monitor
which has been revealed to be the
specials villain which I'll now get into
the crisis on Infinite Earths plot takes
the aesthetic of the original storyline
and updates it for modern audiences this
seminal graphic novel centered around
the heroes of the DC Universe uniting
across the multiverse in order to defeat
the anti-monitor who wanted to destroy
it now potential spoilers here for the
fate of the characters so if you haven't
read the graphic novel yet and don't
want to know and
thing that could ruin the show then I
highly suggest that you skip forward
about a minute but in the original
storyline both the flash Supergirl and
several other key characters including
Alexander Luthor died this is
interesting because Lex will be
appearing from the Supergirl Universe
and this definitely ties in with the
original work the ending of the
storyline is a very bittersweet one with
the universe's becoming merged together
with many of the less popular characters
being cast aside in exchange for a more
streamlined narrative now whether the CW
decide to do this with a merging of the
universes remains to be seen but it's
fair to assume that we will be losing
some heroes in the special with many of
the seasons soon coming to an end in the
wake of it the final season of arrow is
in fact focused on building towards this
giant crossover so it's safe to assume
that the character will be closed out
arrow showrunner Beth Schwartz when
speaking to Entertainment Weekly said
Oliver is told he's going to die
so each episode in the run-up to crisis
has Oliver dealing with the various
stages of grief that come with that
discovery so the theme is really coming
to terms and acceptance mirroring this
the flash will receive a similar
prophecy in his season 6 premiere that
states he too must sacrifice himself in
order to save the universe and the two
characters will have to deal with the
fact that their days are numbered this
will all build towards the final
crossover and will mean that there's
real tension when heading into it this
means that the show really is required
watching and though I myself haven't
been keeping fully up-to-date with
everything this is a great excuse to go
through the series and binge watch as
much as possible so that I can get fully
caught up before the main event I'm sure
many of you will be in the same position
so make sure you leave a like below if
you can't wait to die back into the
universe with this as a new starting off
point now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the crossover so make
sure that you drop them in the comment
section below and if you enjoy this
video and want something else to watch
then please check out my breakdown of
the new spider-man Sony situation and
how I think that the film's will allow
for venom to cross over into them
that'll be linked at the end and it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to keep up today with the Marvel
MCU news you want to come chat to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books there make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey I've also
just started up a discord server which
will be linked in the description so
make sure you get in touch as it's the
best way to keep up to
with the channel and suggest new videos
and topics also just want to let you
know that we're currently giving away a
free copy of spider-man far from home on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
crisis on Infinite Earths in the
comments section below the winner will
be chosen at random on October the 15
then the blu-ray will be shipped out
from then to ever get surprise it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]